die Finanzwelt befindet sich im stetigen
Wandel mit der fortschreitenden
Digitalisierung im 21 Jahrhundert hat
sich dieser Prozess rasant beschleunigt
und neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet Finanzen
anders zu denken digitale Währungen wie
Bitcoin und Co erschüttern positiv und
negativ die Welt mit dem Konzept der
tokenisierung wird ein neues Kapitel in
der Geschichte der Kapitalanlage
aufgeschlagen
dezentral demokratisch kontrollierbar
nonstop das sind die Versprechen der
tokenisierung aber was sind Token
überhaupt und wie funktionieren sie
moconemy wirft einen Blick in die
komplexe Welt der Token durchleuchtet
Theorie und Praxis spricht mit
ExpertInnen aus der Krypto und fintech
[Musik]
Szene schon vor etwa 5000 Jahren
betrieben die Menschen Handel durch den
Tausch von Waren oder
Dienstleistungen im Laufe der Zeit
entwickelten sich Möglichkeiten auch
Anteile an Waren oder Dienstleistungen
zu handeln und sogar an die
Öffentlichkeit zu verkaufen um Kapital
zu
beschaffen so entstanden die
Aktienmärkte wo Unternehmen einzelne
kleine Unternehmensanteile einer
Vielzahl von Investoren anbieten um in
die Zukunft des Unternehmens zu
investieren Bedarf an
anteilisierung hat immer mehr zugenommen
und sich letztlich zu einem weltweiten
Finanzmarkt
entwickelt die tokenisierung deckt
diesen Bedarf in einer noch extremeren
Art und Weise denn hierbei handelt es
sich um eine weitere Segmentierung einer
Einheit oder eines Bestandteils in
weitere einzelne Bestandteile eine Art
bruchteilisierung so können
beispielsweise auch Aktien weiter
bruchtalisiert werden und die so
entstehenden ein ihrerseits gehandelt
werden das Besondere und neue an der
tokenisierung ist dabei nicht die
Segmentierung sondern dessen Verknüpfung
mit einem weiteren Prozess der die
tokenisierung erst interessant macht die
digitale und dezentrale Speicherung der
Bruchteile auf einer
blockchain einzelne Sektoren des Marktes
für tokenisierte Vermögenswerte befinden
sich zurzeit noch in einer Art findungs
oder
Experimentierphase sein Wert wird auf
weniger als Milliarden USDollar
geschätzt dabei beläuft sich der Wert
des Gesamtmarktes für digitale
Vermögenswerte auf etwa 350 Milliarden
US-Dollar hier wird das enorme
Wachstumspotenzial
deutlich die tokenisierung und die
blockchain Technologie könnten den
Finanz und Bankensektor grundlegend
verändern bis
2027 wird sich dieses Wachstum
dramatisch auf schätzungsweise 6,89
Milliarden Dollar
erhöhen fintech ist einer der größten
Akteure die das digitale Token Game
aufmischen werden im Jahr 2022 haben die
Vereinigten Staaten den größten
Marktanteil gehalten aber was ist
eigentlich tokenisierung wie agieren all
diese neue tokenbasierten Akteure auf
dem fintech Markt was ist ihre Agenda
und was sind ihre
Produkte in Europa ist tokeny solutions
mit Sitz in Luxemburg einer der
Marktführer bei der Bereitstellung einer
institutionell und modularen endto-end
Plattform die die Ausgabe den Transfer
und die Verwaltung von handelbaren
digitalen Vermögenswerten also
Sicherheitstoken ermöglicht wie z.B
tokenisierte Darlehen strukturierte
Schuldverschreibungen Aktien und
Fonds dieses private B2B Unternehmen
bietet eine Plattform für die
einheitliche Ausgabe Verwaltung und den
Handel von Dienstleistungs und
Sicherheitstoken die
Unternehmensbewertung für token
solutions liegt zwischen 22 und 33
Millionen USDollar mit einer
Umsatzschätzung von 6,5 Millionen
us-doll für das Jahr und einem Fond von
11 Millionen
US-Dollar das Unternehmen nutzt die
blockchain Technologie von ethereum und
Polygon und arbeitet mit dem ERC
3643 Token
standandard ein weiterer interessanter
Player auf dem europäischen Markt ist
das in Berlin ansässige Unternehmen B
Bond sie haben das erste wertpapiertken
Angebot in Europa eingeführt welches
2019 von der deutschen finanzausicht
bfen genehmigt worden ist bitbond ist
ein Technologieanbieter für tokenisierte
Infrastruktur digitaler Assets Ihr web3
Produkt Token Tool ermöglicht ihren
Kunden die Erstellung Verwaltung und
Verteilung von Token und nfts über EVM
Ketten der bitbond Token oder BB1 ist
ein Security Bond Token der mit Bitcoin
ethereum stellar oder Euro gekauft
werden kann der Wert pro Token
entspricht 1 € ihr globaler Marktanteil
beträgt aktuell weniger als
0,1% wird aber mit einer Teamgröße von
weniger als 50 Personen als Unternehmen
mit ca 7 bis 11 Millionen US-Dollar
bewertet bitbond ist ein privates
Unternehmen mit einem Kapital von 13,2
Millionen Dollar sein z wird 2023 bei
ungefähr einer Million US-Dollar liegen
aber wie funktioniert das genau bitbond
verwendet den erc2 Token Standard dies
ist in der fintech Branche der am
häufigsten verwendete
Sicherheitstoken der Token steht für
tokenisierte Vermögenswerte die den
geltenden Vorschriften für Wertpapiere
entsprechen es sind Wertpapiere in Form
eines Tokens und über ein Unternehmen
wie bitbond oder tokeny solutions kann
der Käufer ein solches Wertpapier als
Token kaufen und Handeln der erworbene
Token wird auf einer blockchain
implementiert die blockchains heißen
ethereum oder Polygon ich bin Ratko
Albrecht Gründer und Geschäftsführer von
bitbond ein Token ist ein Begriff den es
schon lange gibt und er steht im Grunde
dafür dass ein Gegenstand oder ein
digitales gut für etwas anderes steht
wenn man z.B auf eine Kirmis geht und
Eintritt bezahlt bekommt man häufig
einen Token einen Plastik Chip den man
dann im Karussell z.B abgibt und da
kommt der Begriff ursprünglich her mein
Name ist Markus klugel ich bin einer der
coofounder von tokenforge am
bekanntesten ist so der Standard ister
ec20 Standard der im Prinzip tatsächlich
einfach nur ein kleines Register ist in
dem jeder Zugriff erhält der dort ein
Token gemintet bekommen hat und halt
eben mit seinem private key der einzige
ist der IH bewegen kann das ist das was
man so in un der tokenisierung im Block
in der blockchain so versteht und das
ist das was halt eben
ohne Regulierung und ohne Zugriff von
von irgendeinem Administrator oder von
irgendeiner regulierten Partei einfach
mit dem hohen Risiko passiert dass wenn
du deinen private key verlierst du auch
die auf diesen Token nicht mehr
zugreifen kannst und in auch nicht mehr
bewegen kannst und nicht mehr verkaufen
kannst ja aus technischer Sicht ist ein
Token im Grunde ein
datenbanintrag und dort steht drin
welche Adresse das ist im Grunde der
digitale Ort an dem ein Token abgelegt
ist wie viele Stücke wie viele Tokens
hat und implementiert wird das Ganze
durch sogenannten Programmcode der im
Kontext von blockchains auch Smart
contracts genannt wird also smarte
Verträge aber im Grunde ist das erstmal
Programmcode der beschreibt was sind die
technischen Eigenschaften des Tokens und
wem gehört der Token und wer hält diese
Tokens wichtig bei der tokenisierung
also bei der Erschaffung von
Datenbankeinträgen mit denen bestimmte
Rechte der tokeneigentümer verknüpft
sind ist also dass es ein Register gibt
eine Datenbank wo die Einträge
nachlesbar und sicher verwahrt werden
dieses Register gewäht der soeben
erwähnte erc2 Standard es liegt auf
einer blockchain damit es sicher ist der
Token steht für einen Wert oder für eine
Dienstleistung Token so wie wir sie
heute im fintech Bereich verstehen gibt
es ca seit dem Jahr 2014 2015 da ist die
sogenannte ethereum blockchain
entstanden und ethereum blockchain war
die erste Block auf der man Tokens
nämlich digitale Wertgegenstände
erstellen konnte und so hat dann die
ganze Entwicklung begonnen dass es
digitale Tokens gab und seitdem
existiert dieser Begriff im Kontext von
fintech und jetzt haben wir halt eben
die blockchain Technologie mit der mit
der Kryptografie und der Signatur die
halt eben eine ganze Menge mehr an an
Eigenverantwortung
m ja möglich machen weil jeder in dem
Spiel kann halt eben sehen hey das ist
wirklich derjenige der dem das Asset
gehört der ist transferiert das dafür
sorgt halt eben dieses private key
Public Key pa das dann halt eben diese
Sache sicher macht kryptowährungen sind
auch Token sie werden von Unternehmen
oder Institution hergestellt und
verwaltet streng genommen sind
kryptowährungen keine Währungen es sind
digitale Werte die getauscht und
gehandelt werden können ihre Erschaffung
erfolgt durch sogenannte icos der
kurzbegriff für initial coinofer
also der erste das erste sogenannte
initial coin offering war das von
ethereum selbst und die haben im Grunde
das technische Konzept des Tokens
erfunden und haben angefangen das zu
kommerzialisieren und dann kam viele
viele weitere Firmen die sich diese
technischen Möglichkeiten zu Nutze
gemacht haben und weitere Tokens
emittiert
haben mein Name ist Erwin wer ich bin
politischer Leiter der europäischen
blockchain association
wenn Sie der Meinung sind dass Krypto
politisiert ist stimme ich dem zu seit
der Entstehung des Genesis Blocks ist es
politisch denn im Genesis Block also im
ersten Block der Bitcoin blockchain wird
auf das Versagen des Finanzsystems
hingewiesen und Bitcoin als zweite
Rettungsaktion für Banken bezeichnet und
das war während des Höhepunkts der
Finanzkrise im Jahr 2000 sie können sich
den Genesis Block also als eine Art
Streikposten vorstellen es war ein
Protest gegen das was viele Menschen als
finanzielle Ungerechtigkeit ansahen die
auf Kosten der Menschen zum Nutzen einer
Minderheit entstanden
war mit der tokenisierung und
kryptowährung wird ein neues Kapitel in
der Geschichte der Kapitalanlage
geschrieben die neue Art zu investieren
beeinflusst Gesellschaft Politik und
Märkte das revolutionäre Konzept
ermöglicht es Vermögenswerte in beliebig
kleine Teile aufzuteilen die Idee ist
nicht neu
Bruchteilseigentum ist ein beständiger
Trend unter den
Finanzinstrumenten schon seit
Jahrhunderten werden Unternehmen durch
Aktien oder Fonds in kleine Teile
zerlegt gänzlich neu ist es dagegen
diese Bruchteile als digitale Token auf
einer blockchain zu
registrieren aus einer technischen Sicht
gibt es ca drei dominierende technische
Standards es gibt noch viele mehr aber
diese drei technischen Standards mit
denen kann man alle Anwendungsfälle
abbilden die Tokens die dann von
Unternehmen die sich eben der
Technologie zur Nutze machen emittieren
da gibt es tausende wahrscheinlich gibt
es um die 5 Millionen verschiedenen
Token im Moment die aber alle die
gleichen technischen Standards Zug
Grunde haben aber wo andere Werte damit
repräsentiert werden beispielsweise gibt
es sogenannte stable Coins die
repräsentieren fiatwährung wie den Euro
den Dollar dann gibt es Tokens die z.B
Wertpapiere repräsentieren wie Anleihen
oder
Aktien die ermöglicht die Übertragung
von Werten über ein technisches Medium
das viele unterschiedliche Hemmnisse
beseitigen kann dies führt zu
Kosteneinsparungen durch die sofortige
Abwicklung von Anteilen eröffnen sich
neue Anwendungsfälle wie z.B Modelle zur
Nutzung von Dokumenten Transaktionen und
darüber hinaus die Möglichkeit reale
Vermögenswerte in digitalisierter Form
darzustellen und diese den Anlegern von
Finanzprodukten
anzubieten
man kann Schwierigkeiten im
grenzüberschreitenden Zahlungsverkehr
verringern indem man komplexe Prozesse
in kleinere Teile aufgliedert das ist
gerade aus institutioneller Sicht von
Bedeutung es ist wichtig zu erwähnen
dass die tokenisierung innerhalb der
blockchain ein höheres Maß an
finanzieller Handlungsfähigkeit und
finanzieller Inklusion ermöglicht meiner
Meinung nach ist das von größter
Wichtigkeit denn darum geht es doch
letztlich im
Kern sämtliche Vermögenswerte können so
und standardisiert werden dies erhöht
die Liquidität und Transparenz wie nie
zuvor können Prozesse so automatisiert
werden Softwareentwickler haben sich
Gedanken gemacht wie man Tokens
standardisieren kann das hat einen sehr
sehr wichtigen Hintergrund nämlich die
Tokens werden in sogenannten wallets
gehalten das sind im Grunde digitale
Brieftaschen und nicht jede Wallet kann
jede Art von Token verwahren und
deswegen hat man gesagt wir etablieren
einen Standard sass im Grunde alle
wallets möglichst viele Arten von Tokens
verwahren können und da haben Entwickler
Vorschläge gemacht das ist im Endeffekt
Open Source Software und irgendwann hat
der Markt bestimmte technische Standards
präferiert weil man gesagt hat ja die
funktionieren sehr sehr gut und dann
haben die sich verbreitet und
mittlerweile gibt es mit dem sogenannten
rc20 Standard für fungible Token und dem
sogenannten rc721 Standard für die
nonfungiblen Tokens zwei sehr sehr
dominante enstards die kaum noch
wegzudenken sind und ja das waren
einfach Ideen von Entwicklern die sich
durchgesetzt haben und die jetzt
weltweit sehr sehr intensiv genutzt
werden doch der wahre clue der
tokenisierung sind die mit den kleinen
Teilen einhergehenden geringen
Einstiegspreise für
Investoren eine Herausforderung der sich
blockchain kryptowährungen und andere
kryptowährungen im dezentralen
Finanzwesen stellen müssen ist die
Nutzererfahrung die Nutzer dieser
Finanzprodukte und Dienstleistungen kann
oft komplex und anspruchsvoll sein oder
erfordert ein gewisses Maß an
technischem Verständnis das nicht jeder
besitzt am Ende spielt auch das
persönliche Interesse eine Rolle ich
denke nicht dass man sagen kann dass
jeder diese immer und überall nutzen
wird denn das trifft heutzutage auf
alles zu warum sollte es jetzt anders
sein die menschliche Natur ist
wankelmütig daher denke ich dass es
darum gehen sollte die Nutzung so
einfach reibungslos und nahtlos wie
möglich zu gestalten
auch die Emittenten sparen bares Geld
die tokenisierung ermöglicht es Ihnen
einfacher und ohne einen Vermittler an
finanzielle Mittel zu kommen die hohen
Gebühren für die Zusammenarbeit mit
Investmentbanken oder anderen
Institutionen
entfallen ich bin elisabea palasnik ich
unterstütze kryptoasset Dienstleister
Anwaltskanzleien und
Beratungsunternehmen dabei sich
innerhalb der neuen europäischen
Regulierung im Bereich cryptoasset
genannt Mik markets in kryptoets
zurechtzufinden die mika ist ein EU
Rechtsrahmen für kryptowährungen und
Token die auf digitalen Plattformen
gehandelt werden sie ersetzt die
individuellen Regelungen der einzelnen
Länder im Rahmen von Mika liegt mein
Fokus auf bestimmten
kryptovermögenswerten und den
dazugehörigen Dienstleistungen innerhalb
der kryptoindustrie im herkömmlichen
Finanzsektor haben wir bislang die mit
die sämtliche Finanzinstrumente abdeckt
n haben wir zusätzlich die Mik die alle
Arten von kryptovermögenswerten
einbezieht diese sind in drei große
Kategorien eingeteilt nämlich stable
Coins Utility Token und andere
kryptovermögenswerte mit der
Verabschiedung einer markets in
cryptoassets also Mik genannten
Regulierung wurde ein euweit
einheitliches Konzept auf die Schiene
gesetzt ischen Landschaft und ebenso in
der kryptoindustrie führen wie sie
möglicherweise Wissen hatten alle
Nationen hier eine eigene Vorgehensweise
oder manchmal bisher auch überhaupt
keine ich gehe davon aus dass sich
dadurch viele Veränderungen ergeben
werden auch im Finanzsektor warum wenn
Sie heute zu Ihrer Bank gehen und sagen
sie möchten gerne Bitcoin kaufen wird
diese Anfrage höchstwahrscheinlich
abgelehnt einige werden sich darauf
einlassen aber 99% werden sagen nein das
machen wir nicht seitdem in krafttreten
von Mik können Sie diese
Dienstleistungen nun vermehrt nutzen
vorausgesetzt sie Vertrauen ihrer Bank
oder ihrem Broker und er oder sie
verfügt über das nötige Wissen und die
nötige
Erfahrung kryptowährungen werden über
kryptobörsen gehandelt
Utility Token repräsentieren einen
bestimmten Nutzen oder eine bestimmte
Funktionalität auf einer
Plattform es gibt verschiedene Arten von
Token die als Finanzinstrumente dienen
können Security Token fungieren als
digitale Wertpapiere sie können die
Eigenschaften von Aktien oder Anleihen
haben ein Security Token ist ein Token
der normalerweise ein Wertpapier
verbrieft und aus technischer Sicht
nimmt man dort häufig den rc20 Token der
ein fungibler Token ist aber mit einigen
Ergänzungen z.B ist es bei Wertpapieren
häufig wichtig zu wissen wer hält diese
Token und dort gibt es bestimmte
technische Einstellungen die man
vornehmen kann damit diese token nicht
überall hin verschickt werden können
sondern nur an bestimmte Empfänger die
auf einer sogenannten Whitelist sind das
bedeutet man hat freigegeben welche
Empfänger diesen Token halten dürfen und
Security Token werden technisch eben
häufig so ausgestaltet weil die
Emittenten diejenigen diese Token
herausgeben häufige wissen möchten oder
auch teilweise gesetzlich wissen müssen
wer diese Token hält dann gibt es Tokens
die als Utility Token bezeichnet werden
das sind häufig plattformspzifische
Währungen das kann man sich so
vorstellen dass beispielsweise auf
sozialen Medien nicht mit normalem Geld
bezahlt wird sondern mit einem Token der
speziell für diese Plattform erstellt
wurde und dafür kann man dann bestimmte
Dinge auf dieser Plattform nutzen der
Prozess der tokenisierung beginnt mit
der Erfassung von Informationen über den
Vermögenswert dies kann beispielsweise
eine detaillierte Beschreibung einer
Immobilie sein oder eine Liste der
Kunstwerke in einer Sammlung mit all
ihren individuellen
Eigenschaften diese Informationen werden
dann in eine digitale Form konvertiert
und gespeichert anschließend wird ein
Token generiert der die Eigentumsrechte
an dem beschriebenen Sachwert
repräsentiert der Token wird ebenfalls
auf der blockchein gespeichert und
enthält dank der individuellen
Informationen einen eindeutigen
digitalen Fingerabdruck des
Vermögenswerts es gibt eine ganze Menge
Widerstand einfach
weil ja weil eine neue Technologie ist
und tatsächlich auch ein
Paradigmenwechsel in der
Herangehensweise also wenn man früher
irgendwie etwas von A nach B bewegt hat
also ein Wertpapier deswegen wurden die
Wertpapiere als solche auch gemacht dann
hat man sie wirklich von A nach B bewegt
und jetzt hast du halt ein
registergedanken der einfach sagt ich
ändere das Zugriffsrecht auf diese auf
diesen Token und also indem ich den
transferiere das heißt
das Wertpapier klebt jetzt an dem Asset
und ist nicht mehr ein freib
beewegliches Wertpapier und das hat eine
ganze Menge Implikationen in den
Prozessen ja und es ist jetzt einfach
unsere Aufgabe dass wir in der Lage sind
all die Technologien all die
Möglichkeiten die man jetzt
zusammenstecken kann also digitale
Identitäten digitale Währungen und halt
eben die tokenisierung so
zusammenstecken dass halt eben der
Zugriff halt eben wirklich
demokratisiert wird sobald ein Token
erstellt und auf einer blockchain
gespeichert wurde kann er durch Smart
contracts verwaltet werden
über Smart contracts können
Mietzahlungen anteilig an einen Investor
transferiert werden sobald die Miete
eingegangen ist oder er veranlasst
automatisch Zahlungen sobald bestimmte
Meilensteine in einem Projekt erreicht
werden das faszinierende an Token ist
dass es sich im Grunde um
programmierbare Werte handelt die auf
einer blockchain registriert
sind ich möchte hier nicht von Geld
sprechen weil es einen Unterschied
zwischen Geld und seiner regulierten und
übertragbaren Werte gibt aber es ist
wichtig wenn wir z. über Nachhaltigkeit
nachdenken dass wir nicht nur einen
neuen digitalen Vermögenswert einführen
sondern auch damit bestimtes Signal
setzen wir müssen ihm also eine
Bedeutung verleihen die einem bestimmten
Wert entspricht und das wird denke ich
der wichtigste Aspekt der tokenisierung
sein dass wir sowohl digitale Maßstäbe
setzen als auch seine Nutzung optimieren
und Anreize für bestimmte Praktiken
schaffen
können das Investieren in tokenisierte
Immobilien ist eine der neuesten
Entwicklungen in der
Immobilienbranche die tokenisierung
macht es möglich dass Häuser und
Wohnungen nicht nur als einzelne
Einheiten sondern beliebig kleinteilig
segmentiert und gehandelt werden können
hier sind es kleine Programme die als
technische Brücke zwischen der Immobilie
und einer Online Verkaufsplattform
dienen Token schaffen ein digitales
Abbild einer Immobilie und machen sie so
digital
handelbar Problem ist dabei dass viele
Anleger dementsprechend entweder nicht
in der Größen Ordnung einsteigen möchten
in diesen Markt oder nicht einsteigen
können weil ihnen beispielsweise das
Eigenkapital fehlt oder sie keine
Fremdfinanzierung bekommen und die Idee
und der große Vorteil der tokenisierung
ist jetzt diese kleinste Einheit die
erwerbbar ist sehr viel kleiner zu
machen ein Wohnungsbesitzer kann
beispielsweise eine Wohnung die einen
Wert von 100.000 € hat in 1000 Token
zerlegen jeder Token hat dann einen Wert
von 100 € und repräsentiert einen
winzigen Prozentsatz der
Immobilie mit jedem Token erwerben die
Anleger das Recht auf einen bestimmten
Prozentsatz der Mieteinnahmen davon
werden Kosten wie die Grundsteuer
Reparaturen oder Versicherungen
abgezogen wenn die Wohnung mit der Zeit
an Wert gewinnt und auch die
Mieteinnahmen steigen steigt auch der
Wert des Tokens ein weiterer Vorteil der
tokenisierung ist die jederzeitige
Handelbarkeit der einzelnen Token
letztenendes 24 7 über Apps oder
Handelsplattformen und man muss eben
nicht mehr zum Notar gehen und dort eine
Beurkundung stattfinden lassen um eine
Immobilie bzw einen Anteil an einer
Immobilie zu
erwerben der Erwerber verwaltet seine
Token ganz einfach mit Hilfe einer
Wallet App je nach Ausgestaltung der App
kann man nicht nur zahlungseangänge
überprüfen oder sich die
Wertveränderungen seiner Token als
Diagramm ausgeben lassen sondern die
Token sogar direkt über das Smartphone
wieder verkaufen
immobilientoken werden derzeit wie
Wertpapiere behandelt Käufer besitzen
insofern keinen physischen Anteil an
einer Immobilie ein immobilientoken ist
im Prinzip ein Darlehen das der Anbieter
der Token zur Finanzierung der Immobilie
nutzt die Zinsen für dieses Darlehen
werden aus den Mieteinnahmen gezahlt das
birgt ein gewisses Verlustrisiko es
drohen Mietausfälle und schlimmstenfalls
sogar die Insolvenz des anbiet
dieses Risiko ist insofern höher als bei
einem Immobilienfond über den man in der
Regel in viele Immobilien gleichzeitig
investiert in Deutschland ist ein
solches Szenario allerdings noch
Zukunftsmusik weil es hier derzeit noch
an einem regulatorischen Rahmen fehlt
der eine derartige Verbriefung von
Eigentumsrechten an Grundstücken und
Immobilien möglich machen würde die
Prozesse die mit einem Immobilienkauf
einhergehen bleiben daher vorerst noch
mit viel Bürokratie zeitaaufwand und
damit auch hohen Kosten
verbunden wirklich bekannt wurde die
tokenisierung aber durch digitale
Kunstprojekte mit Hilfe von nonfungible
Tokens können einzigartige digitale
Güter dargestellt werden der
amerikanische Künstler bipel
versteigerte im März
2021 eine digitale Kollage aus 5
für beispiellose
69,35 Millionen USDollar Twitter Gründer
Jack dys erster Tweet war einem Fan
satte 2,9 Millionen USDollar
Wert mein Name ist everfres auch bekannt
als Sebastian
P so etwas wie im Jahr 2021 werden wir
nicht mehr sehen das Schiff ist bereits
abgefahren ich hoffe jedoch dass der
Kunstmarkt nochas erwachener wir
Künstler vernünftige Preise für Ihre
digitalen Werke erzielen und auch davon
leben
können nicht jeder Künstler wird das
schaffen aber darum geht es auch nicht
so funktioniert der Markt eben nicht es
schaffen nur
wenige man sieht eine ständig steigende
Anzahl der Leute die kryptokunst sammel
ich
hee und CEO von magal magal steht für
Meta Art
Gallery im Januar 2021 gab es eine Blase
bei der der kryptokunstmarkt NFT um
14000% Anstieg allerdings fällt man nach
einem solchen höhenfug auch sehr schnell
wieder wir versuchen im Moment ein
sinnvolles Niveau zu erreichen von dem
aus wir gemeinsam mit Krypto Bitcoin und
allem was dazu gehört wachsen
können kunsttokens können von überall
auf der gekauft werden das ermöglicht
globale Investitionen in
Kunst twitter ist die beste Plattform um
seine Werke innerhalb der NFT Welt
bekannt zu machen es gibt zwar auch
andere Social Media Plattformen aber
twitter ist einindeutig die
effektivste ich erreiche mein Publikum
vor allem über Twitter natürlich
veröffentliche ich meine Werke auch auf
anderen Plattformen aber bisher habe ich
keine vergleichbaren verk durch andere
Plattformen derzeit liegt der größte
Trend darin Dinge aus dem metaverse ins
reale Leben zu bringen man kann
kryptokunst nur wirklich wahrnehmen wenn
man sie sehen und berühren kann ähnlich
wie hier auf unseren Bildschirmen diesen
Weg sollten Galeristen
einschlagen mit Hilfe der nonfungible
Tokens werden digitale Kunstgegenstände
in der Regel als Ganzes in der
blockchain verbrie selbst wenn ein
Künstler mehrere des exakt gleichen
Bildes generiert hat jeder einzelne eine
einzigartige Identität in der blockchain
und das bedeutet das sind Token die im
Grunde einindeutig sind wir können uns
das so ein bisschen in der realen Welt
vorstellen wenn wir einen Euro eine
Euromünze in der Hand halten dann ist es
uns egal ob wir die eine oder die andere
Euromünze haben weil sie sind in ihrer
Kaufkraft absolut identisch und wir
unterscheiden das nicht das wären
sogenannte fungible Tokens und das
gleiche trifft auch auf Wertpapiere zu
wenn ich eine bmw- Aktie habe ist es mir
egal ob ich die eine oder die andere
bmw- Aktie habe die bmw- Aktie verbrie
das gleiche Recht ich habe das gleiche
Stimmrecht und den gleichen Wert bei
nfts den sogenannten nonfungible Token
die kann man eher zu Kunstwerken
vergleichen wenn ich beispielsweise ein
Picasso Bild oder die Monalisa besitzen
würde dann ist diese eineindeutig es mag
fäs schon geben aber die echte Monalisa
gibt es nur einmal die ist nicht
fungibel sondern es gibt eben nur diese
eine und jedes andere Bild ist wieder
anders es gibt auch das Konzept der
Drucke in der Kunst wo z.B ein Fotodruck
eine limitierte Auflage hat 100 Stück
beispielsweise und jedes einzelne Foto
hat dann eine Nummer und es gibt eben
diese Serie auch so kann man nonfungible
Tokens verwenden aber es ist immer so
gedacht dass jeder Token einindeutig
identifizierbar ist werden bei den
fungiblen wertpapiertken alle Tokens
identisch und austauschbar sind
es existieren gewisse Grauzonen im
Zusammenhang mit NFT vieles existiert
unter dem Oberbegriff Defi aber
grundsätzlich fallen NFT nicht unter
Defi sondern werden durch die Mika
geregelt wenn etwas in Serie oder einer
großen Auflage ausgegeben wird ist das
ein Indikator für Austauschbarkeit und
somit kein NFT aber was bedeutet große
Auflage wie wird diese definiert und wir
hoffen dass wir diese Grauzonen mit der
Zeit abschaffen werden wir bemühen uns
diesff in Zukunft klar zu definieren
auch wenn es schwierig wird da die
technologische Entwicklung so rasant
ist die meisten NFT Verkäufe sind
eigentlich
Auktionen es sind keine klassischen
Auktionen bei denen ein Mann mit einem
Hammer erscheint normalerweise stellt
man sein Objekt auf einer Plattform zu
einem Mindestpreis zur Verfügung danach
kann man die Dauer der Auktion mittels
eines Timers
festlegen
üblicherweise dauert diese 24 Stunden
wie lange sie tatsächlich dauert hängt
davon ab ob andere Personen auch Gebote
abgeben ob der Preis steigt oder
nicht die meisten Plattformen verlangen
eine Gebühr von 5 bis 15% es gibt auch
einige die verlangen 20% aber der
Großteil liegt bei
15% die tokenisierung kann so zu einem
wichtigen Instrument werden um für ein
breites Publikum zugänglicher zu machen
Investitionen in Kunst werden so einfach
sicher und zuverlässig auch für die
Künstler selbst könnte die tokenisierung
ein spannendes Vehikel für den Verkauf
ihrer Werke sein theoretisch kann der
Künstler sich sogar selbst den
Investoren als Kapitalanlage anbieten
steigt sein Wert profitieren die Anleger
auf der anderen Seite generiert der
Künstler ein regelmäßiges
Zusatzeinkommen der Kunstmarkt nach wie
vor noch verhältnismäßig intransparent
und deswegen braucht man eben tiefe
Kenntnisse von den Playern den
Einflussfaktoren den Dynamiken an diesem
Markt um kompetitiv unterwegs sein zu
können wenn man Kunstwerke
kauft die Arbeiten die wir im Portfolio
haben der Top 100 künstlerinn und
Künstler die findet man eben nicht beim
wald- und wiesengaleristen um die Ecke
sondern in der Regel bei den
international führenden Galerien und
wenn man diese Zugänge nicht hat dann
kommt man entweder gar nicht an die
Kunstwerke oder zu sehr überteuerten
Preisen weil die Kunstwerke dann eben
schon mehrere handelsschritte
durchlaufen haben und jeder
handelsschritt wird man geht mit einer
verteuerungh Bruchteilseigentum an einem
Vermögenswert wird im Bereich der Kunst
über sogenannte Art Security Tokens oder
Asts abgebildet das sind digitale
Vermögenswerte die einem Teil an einem
Kunstwerk entsprechen dieser Markt war
bisher allerdings nur sehr sehr
wohlhabenden Menschen zugänglich allein
schon aufgrund der hohen Kaufpreise die
diese Kunstwerke haben da reden wir von
sechs siebenstelligen Beträgen teilweise
drüber und die wenigsten Menschen haben
eben das Geld um sich diese Kunst
leisten zu können und wir ändern das
arttrade kümmert sich artrade sourc die
Kunstwerke das heißt wir unterhalten
Netzwerk von Kunstexperten mit dem wir
attraktive Werke erstmal identifizieren
das ganze wird quergeschnitten mit einem
sehr aufwendigen
datenanalyseprozess und die Kunstwerke
wenn wir dann eins identifiziert haben
dann fraktional ieren wir sie sozusagen
digital wir geben pro Kunstwerk ein
digitales Wertpapier aus in Form von
sogenannten Security Token ein Euro
Emissionswert des Kunstwerkes entspricht
dabei einem Token der Security Token den
wir ausgeben das ist letztlich ein
digitales Wertpapier voll reguliert nach
ewpg nach dem neuen elektronischen
wertpapiergesetz ja das enthält auch
eine ISIN und das ermöglicht es uns eben
diesen Token und das Wertpapier ähm zu
behandeln wie andere klassische
Wertpapiere auch und sie letztlich in
die auch eine Infrastruktur der
Finanzindustrie zu integrieren mit ihrer
Hilfe kann nun jeder in Kunstwerke
investieren die es unter normalen
Umständen niemals in das Anlageportfolio
des durchschnittsanlegers schaffen
würden man kann bereits ab 1000 €
mittelbar in diese Kunstwerke
investieren indem man diese Token kauft
ja und so an der Wertentwicklung der
Kunstwerke partizipieren und dadurch
sorgen wir eben dafür dass man schon mit
kleineren Beträgen an ganz großer Kunst
eben teilhaben kann selbst die alten
Meister finden sich inzwischen auf der
blockchain erst vor kurzem wurde Pablo
Picassos Meisterwerk fiet obereé auf
einer blockchain
tokenisiert verantwortlich ist eine in
Zürich ansässige kryptobank die das
Ölgemälde in 4000 der kunsttoken
zerlegte und diese für jeweeils 1000
Schweizer Franken
verkaufte
dafür wurden die Token wiederum in
blockchain basierte Wertpapiere
umgewandelt die in der Schweiz einen
unstrittigen Rechtsanspruch auf das
einzigartige Gemälde von 1964
darstellen als Anlegerin oder Anleger
hat man letztlich am Ende nicht ein
Stück des Kunstwerkes sondern einen
verbrieften Anspruch an der
Wertentwicklung dieses Kunstwerkes zu
partizipieren wir haben uns bewusst
gegen beruchteilseigentum entschieden
und für ein Wertpapier weil es dann
letztlich
ähm ja einem klassischen
Investmentprodukt entspricht ja und auch
im Finanzsystem entsprechend integriert
werden kann bei Arbeiten die auf dem
Sekundärmarkt gehandelt werden heißt wo
es schon einen Käufer gab und die werden
dann weiter gehandelt da ähm ähm
partizipiert der Künstler oder die
Künstlerin in der Regel nicht mehr dran
perspektivisch ist das aber schon ein
Modell was wir ausbauen wollen denn es
gibt die Möglichkeit in die Token in die
Smart contracts eben auch hinein zu
strukturieren dass der Künstler über
gewissen Prozentsatz an der
Wertentwicklung des Kunstwerkes auch
dauerhaft beteiligt bleibt aber das ist
noch
Zukunft wenn ich mir anschaue was meine
Kinder sammeln Fortnite Skins oder
digitale Waffen für Spiele dann sehe ich
eine vielversprechende Zukunft voraus
das Sammeln von digitaler Kunst
elt dieser Art des
sammels Picasso oder ölgem
werden die Leute nicht mehr an die Wand
hängen auch meine Kinder nicht sie
werden andere Kunstwerke
sammeln auch die Finanzierung großer
Kunstgalerien Museen Sammlungen und
Lagereinrichtungen für Kunstwerke könnte
in naher Zukunft von der tokinisierung
profitieren denn sie investieren
Unsummen in den Schutz ihrer
Kunstgegenstände Diebstahl Vandalismus
das zu verhindern kostet Geld Geld das
die Museen nicht haben
diesen Institutionen fehlt es an
Liquidität die Eintrittsgelder und
Fördertöpfe reichen häufig nicht um die
Sammlungen zu erweitern die
tokenisierung könnte ihnen zu dieser
Liquidität verhelfen sie könnte die
Sammlungen oder einen ausgesuchten Teil
davon für Investoren verfügbar machen
die einen Gewinn aus der Wertsteigerung
der Kunstwerke
ziehen eine Aktie ist ein von im
Unternehmen ausgegebenes Wertpapier je
nach Art der Aktie kann das ein Anspruch
auf einen Teil des Gewinns auf
Dividenden oder ein Mitspracherecht sein
Unternehmen geben Aktien aus um
zusätzliche Mittel für ihre
Geschäftsentwicklung zu beschaffen doch
trotz der Digitalisierung bleibt der
Handel mit Aktien an vielen Stellen
ineffizient wer in Aktien investieren
möchte der muss eine ganze Aktie kaufen
die Aktien großer Unternehmen Kosten
jedoch oftmals über
USDollar das schränkt den Kreis derer
die sich das leisten können ein und
selbst wenn man sich einen Teil der
großen Unternehmen sichert entfällt
dadurch automatisch die Möglichkeit das
Portfolio durch Investitionen in mehrere
Aktien zu
diversifizieren mein Name ist Philip
Piper ich bin einer der Mitbegründer von
Swarm wir sind eine Plattform die sowohl
Erstausgabe als auch sekundärhandel vom
Token
anbietet in den Letten Z Jahren rückten
massive kryptoassets in den Fokus der
Öffentlichkeit also im Grunde Bitcoin
und andere native Vermögenswerte die auf
eine blockchain wie z.B die auf ethereum
basieren es hat sich jedoch gezeigt dass
zwischen all diesen Vermögenswerten eine
starke Korrelation besteht wenn der
Markt wächst dann steigen auch die
Preise der Assets schrumpft der Markt
jedoch fallen die Preise oder brechen
ein es ist daher notwendig dass reale
Vermögenswerte in der Kette repliziert
werden welche ihren Wert direkt a dem
zugrunde liegenden Vermögenswert
ableiten der mit diesem digitalen
Vermögenswert verbunden ist ein gutes
Beispiel hierfür ist ein sogenannter
stablecoin die tokenisierung ermöglicht
es Bruchteile der Aktien dieser großen
Unternehmen zu kaufen anstatt eine ganze
Aktie zu kaufen kann man so nur einen
Teil einer Aktie kaufen und damit eine
anteilige Rendite
erwirtschaften mit Hilfe der
tokenisierung werden digitale Abbilder
von bereits herausgegeben Wertpapieren
geschaffen man spricht von
tokenderivaten diese werden in der
blockchain verbrieft und so in eine
flexiblere Infrastruktur eingebettet so
erhält man im Prinzip eine normale Aktie
aber mit den Vorteilen von
kryptowährungen der Kurs der
tokenisierten Aktie entspricht immer dem
Aktienkurs des ausgebenden Unternehmens
wenn sich der Wert der hinterlegten
Aktie verdoppelt verdoppelt sich auch
der Wert der tokenisierten Aktie die
Kursentwicklung d ähnlich wie bei Aktien
analysiert nicht wie bei
kryptowährungen ein stablecoin kann im
Grunde ein Token sein der einen Dollar
repräsentiert er entspricht also einem
Dollar dadurch haben wir die Möglichkeit
alles was eine Art Wert besitzt in die
blockchain und deren Trading Umgebung zu
bringen und sind in der Lage diese
Vermögenswerte zu fraktionieren bzw zu
digitalisieren es gibt ein sehr großes
Spektrum von verschiedenen
Vermögenswerten die man so als digitalen
Vermögenswert in die blockchain bringen
kann wenn Sie eine Apple Aktie besitzen
die durch einen Token repräsentiert wird
warum sollen sie dann nicht auch einen
Cent der Aktie erwerben können wenn sie
das möchten das funktioniert nicht auf
den traditionellen Finanzmärkten die
tokenisierung reduziert die
Einstiegshürden an den neuen
Finanzmärkten dadurch erheblich der
überwiegende Teil aller Unternehmen
weltweit sind derzeit
Privatunternehmen es gibt ähnliche
Produkte die imtieren aber sie bieten
nicht das gleiche Maß an Flexibilität
zweitens erhält man die Möglichkeit
einer sofortigen Abwicklung an einer
dezentralen Börse oder einem
Handelsplatz können wir uns auf einen
Preis einigen und das Geschäft sofort
über die blockchain abwickeln die
Übertragung meines Eigentums auf den
bisherigen Finanzmärkten kann bis zu 2 D
Tage
dauern aus politischer Sicht besitzt die
USA auch gerade wegen des Dollars eine
Sonderstellung hat einmal gesagt der
Dollar sei zwar die Währung der
Vereinigten Staaten aber das Problem
aller anderen das sehe ich nicht so denn
ich denke dass der Dollar auch für die
Vereinigten Staaten ein Problem
darstellt in anderen Ländern gibt es
bereits Gerichtsbarkeiten die im Grunde
Vorschriften für den digitalen US-Dollar
schaffen nichts davon kommt bisher aus
den USA die Regulierung von stable Coins
gehört zu den low hanging fruits es wäre
somit das einfachste Mittel um die
Position Dollars wieder zu stärken und
das ist nicht die Position die Europa im
gleichen Maße vertritt ich meine der
US-Dollar macht immer noch etwa 60% der
weltweiten Geldreserven aus das
politische System der Vereinigten
Staaten ist von seiner Konzeption her
eher kämpferisch für Wettbewerb
konzipiert und man sollte das immer
bedenken wenn man die USA
betrachtet die tokenisierten Aktien
schlagen damit eine Brücke zwischen den
traditionellen Wertpapierbörsen wie der
Xetra oder der Börse Frank und einer
kryptobörse wie
binance je nach Netzwerk und kryptobörse
können tokentr transansaktionen in
wenigen Minuten abgewickelt
werden die Möglichkeit rund um die Uhr
handeln zu können ohne dass die Märkte
stillstehen stellt einen klaren Vorteil
da das bringt den Menschen reales Geld
wenn man dies mit Steuerungsprozessen
verknüpfen kann ist das ebenfalls ein
Vorteil weil man eine viel direktere
Interaktion hat
und die transaktionsprozesse
uneingeschränkt verfolgen kann aber noch
wichtiger ist das entstehende Vertrauen
auf die Daten die mit dem Token
verbunden sind diese zeichnen ein Bild
vom tatsächlichen Wert und Berichten mit
liveeden dadurch ist man plötzlich nicht
mehr auf einen Quartalsbericht
angewiesen sondern man hat einen
Überblick in Echtzeit das Smart contract
Transaktionen von tokenisierten
Wertpapieren auf einer blockchain
abwickeln ist das Vertrauen in einen
Broker oder Banker als Vermittler nicht
mehr
notwendig ich würde sagen dies sind im
Großen und Ganzen einige der Aspekte in
denen die tokenisierung die
Finanzindustrie verändern wird
unabhängig davon ob man glaubt dass es
eine vollständige Abschaffung der
Zwischenhändler geben wird oder nicht es
wird sicherlich die Rolle der
Finanzvermittler einschränken oder deren
Anzahl bei bestimmten
Finanztransaktionen
reduzieren in der Welt der tokenisierung
hat letztlich alles einen Bezug zu einem
realen Wert oder Gegenstand es wird ein
Vertrauensverhältnis geschaffen das
bedeutet selbst wenn ein Token verloren
geht was immer darauf ankommt wie sie
ihr Investment gestalten man immer
sicherstellen kann dass entweder der
aktuelle Besitzer anerkannt wird oder
dass der Token an den ursprünglichen
Besitzer zurückgeht also einfach eine
sehr effiziente
Technologie der Verkauf von
Unternehmensanteilen ist bürokratisch
dauert lange und es sind viele Akteure
involviert die technischen Möglichkeiten
haben wir und wir müssen jetzt gucken
dass die beiden Extreme zusammen bringen
haben wir einmal die traditionelle Welt
die sagt wir wollen das alles über
Clearstream weiter abhandeln weil sich
das einfach über die letzten Jahrzehnte
einfach sehr stabil erwiesen hat und
natürlich auch der Stakeholder drin sind
die die ihr Geld damit verdienen
logischerweise ja und auf der anderen
Seite haben wir die die Defi und die die
kryptowelt die sagt wir wollen alles in
Selbstbestimmung machen und wie meistens
liegt die Wahrheit wahrscheinlich
irgendwo in der Mitte und das müssen wir
halt eben jetzt auch entsprechend bauen
Investoren haben zu diesen Unternehmen
keinen Zugang Investitionen werden
hauptsächlich von Finanzinstituten in
Form teurer Kredite oder
Beteiligungsfonds getätigt der Markt
verfügt daher über eine minimale
Liquidität ja ich denke es wird sich
eher auf den B2B Bereich auswirken weil
wir als Endnutzer in erster Linie an
Benutzerfreundlichkeit und natürlich an
Sicherheit interessiert sind wir sind
weniger daran interessiert ob eine Bank
oder fintech App nun Technologie A oder
B verwendet vor allem wenn wir über
Massenanwendungen sprechen dann sollten
Unternehmen keine Rolle spielen es muss
einfach eine gut funktionierende
wenn investiert wird dann fast immer
langfristig schlägt die
Unternehmensführung eine andere Richtung
ein können die Investoren nicht einfach
aussteigen sie versuchen dann Einfluss
auf die Unternehmensführung zu nehmen
die Prozesse werden
Träger wenn man jetzt denkt dass es sich
um ein komplett offenes Netzwerk handelt
zu dem jeder Zugang hat dann ist das
nicht ganz richtig der Aufbau des
Systems hängt sehr stark vom
Vermögenswert der gehandelt wird na
Vermögenswert gibt es kungen die man
natürlich im System berücksichtigen muss
damit nur eine bestimmte Art von Kunden
die Token kaufen kann oder man setzt
konkrete Standards im Nutzerverhalten
damit der Handel mit Token ausgeführt
werden kann es handelt sich also um sehr
technologiebedingte Einschränkungen aber
es schafft auch ein viel höheres Maß an
Vertrauen in den Regulierungsprozess da
sich um einen Code handelt der exakt das
umsetzt was angefragt wurde und dieser
kann nicht wirklich umgangen
werden wir gehen davon aus dass die
tokenisierung und die blockchain
Technologie eine große Rolle spielen
werden um Prozesse effizienter und
schlanker zu gestalten das ist der erste
Schritt hinzu kommt die tokenisierung
und auch die blockchain Technologie
dafür zu nutzen um verschiedene
Vermögenswerte auf verschiedene Weise zu
finanzieren und zu tokenisieren dieser
wachstumsaspekt hängt sowohl stark von
der kommenden Regulierung als auch von
den strategischen Entscheidungen einiger
Neo blockchainbank BZ Playern auf dem
Markt ab wir können davon ausgehen dass
wir in der nächsten Zeit neue
Anwendungsfälle und eine ganze Reihe
neuer Konzepte sehen werden das bedeutet
völlig neue Kategorien von
anwendungswellen die es so noch nicht
gibt in Diskussionen über die Zukunft
der Energiewirtschaft wird immer
häufiger auch über energietokenisierung
gesprochen wir leben in einer Zeit in
der erneuer em populär geworden sind
immer mehr Anleger investieren in Wind
und
Solarparks mein Name ist eo ich bin
Geschäftsführer von realport die
Dezentralisierung der Energie ist
bereits im Gange und wird sich weiter
beschleunigen ich glaube dass die
letzten Jahre mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine und dem Wunsch der Regierungen
unabhängiger zu werden einen
unglaublichen Boom bei solardchern und
Energie erzeugt
haben mit der Entwicklung von
Unternehmen und Lieferketten wird es für
Mieter und Hausbesitzer noch einfacher
werden Solaranlagen auf ihren Dächern zu
installieren und dann geht es darum dass
die verschiedenen dezentralen
Knotenpunkte miteinander verbunden
werden also von Dach zu Dach und
intelligent in das Stromnetz eingebunden
werden und ich denke dass die
Technologie dai wichtige Rolle spielen
wird doch das komplexe Netzwerk des
Energiesektors leidet unter einer
veralteten Infrastruktur hinzu kommen
zahlreiche ineffiziente Prozesse mit
Hilfe der blockchain kann die Effizienz
der Energieversorgung erhöht
werden und Effizienz bedeutet
Kostenersparnis Kostenersparnis bedeutet
kleinere Projekte und somit auch dass es
nur eine überschaubare Gruppe von
Investoren braucht was für viele
Menschen von Vorteil ist macht vieles
effizienter macht den Zugang effizienter
und ermöglicht auch kleinere Windparks
die Teilnahme an der Energiewirtschaft
durch ihre dezentrale Architektur ist
sie in der Lage die Lieferketten
verschiedene Energieerzeuger
gleichzeitig zu dokumentieren bei
zentralisierten Systemen ist dies
deutlich aufwendiger hier muss jeder
Erzeuger seine Daten zunächst an eine
zentrale Stelle schicken an der die
Daten gebündelt und aufbereitet werden
können in einem dezentralen
blockchainnetzwerk kann nun je die Daten
direkt einspeisen mit Hilfe der
tokenisierung kann für jede physische
Energieeinheit eine digitale Version auf
einer blockchain gespeichert werden
durch diese Automatisierung der
Verwaltungsprozesse kann Energie so
deutlich billiger
werden auf der anderen Seite sehen wir
dass es zwei verschiedene Formen gibt
eine Form besteht in der Aufteilung der
wirtschaftlichen Leistung eines
energieprojekts oder eines Teils eines
Projekts für erneuerbare Energien also
ein Erzeuger möchte einen Windpark
errichten und benötigt dazu Investoren
denen er verspricht dass die Einnahmen
aus dem Windpark unter den Investoren
aufgeteilt werden somit sind wir also in
Zukunft in der Lage Einnahmen aus dieser
Investition in Token umzuwandeln und
damit dieses Projekt zu finanzieren der
viel schwierigere Teil ist die Frage wie
wir erneuerbare Energien durch nationale
Agenturen zertifizieren und in gewissem
Sinne fungibel oder handelbar
machen
[Musik]
die blockchain Technologie ermöglicht es
zudem die Energie von der Quelle bis zum
Endverbraucher zu verfolgen falls nötig
können Zertifikate ausgestellt werden
die den Kauf belegen das kann speziell
bei den strengen Regularien der
erneuerbaren Energie ein entscheidendes
Kriterium sein derzeit weiß im Grunde
niemand ob die Energie aus Wind Solar
oder einer anderen Quelle stammt die
Herkunft muss ein dritter bescheinigen
diese Zertifikate werden gehandelt
Greenwashing wird
begünstigt es gibt verschiedene
rechtliche und regulatorische Aspekte
die damit verbunden sind an erster
Stelle steht die EU Taxonomie die uns
vorgibt was grün ist und was nicht das
ist eine Orientierungshilfe für
Investoren und Emittenten von
Finanzprodukten zweitens gibt es eine
Verordnung zur nachhaltigkeitsbezogenen
Offenlegungspflicht sfdr jeder Emittent
von Finanzprodukten muss selbst
beurteilen ob er hoch nachhaltig ist
Artikel 9 oder nicht nachhaltig Artikel
7 und das wird den Verbrauchern eine
enorme Orientierungshilfe sein welche
Dienstleistungen grün sind und welche
nicht das bedeutet also dass der
Spielraum für Greenwashing sehr viel
kleiner
wird dank der tokenisierung kann ein
tokenisiertes Zertifikat direkt vom
Erzeuger erstellt werden die Zertifikate
werden dann direkt in der blockchain
gespeichert sass die Daten nicht mehr
verändert werden können die Herkunft der
erzeugten Energie ist so garantiert
Governance Token ist eine bestimmte Art
von Token die von bestimmten Unternehmen
häufig
techunternehmen oder auch sogenannten
decentralized autonomous organizations
emittiert werden die Governance Token
haben bestimmte Rechte im Grunde aus
einch technischen Sicht sind sie häufig
sogenannte erc20 Tokens das heißt die
Folgen dem Standard den auch viele
andere tokenarten verwenden aber das
recht was der Besitzer dieses Governance
Tokens hat das unterscheidet sich
vielleicht z.B von wertpapiertken die
Governance Token verbrrieen hufig
Stimmrechte und die werden eben von
Unternehmen herausgegeben und wenn das
Unternehmen etwas ändern möchte wenn es
technische Änderungen z.B implementieren
möchte dann habe ich ein Stimmrecht wenn
ich Stücke dieser Governance Token halte
das bedeutet ich habe nicht nur einen
monetären Anreiz diesen Token zu halten
und hoffe vielleicht auf einen zukünft
Gewinn sondern ich habe auch ein
Mitbestimmungsrecht und ich kann mich in
Communities engagieren und meine Stimme
wird eben gehört anhand der Anzahl der
Tokens die ich
halte die große Herausforderung besteht
nun darin wie die Verbraucher seines
Geschäftskunden oder sogar normale
Einzelhandelskunden zertifizierte
erneuerbare Energiequellen erwerben
können und hier kann die blockchain
einen enormen Vorteil bieten die Vision
ist dass man eines Tages in der Lage
sein wird Zertifikate zumit der
Produktion mit dem Verbrauch zum
Zeitpunkt des tatsächlichen Bedarfs
abzugleichen durch die tokenisierung
werden Windparks oder andere erneuerbare
Energiequellen für Kapitalanleger viel
einfacher zugänglich per Token in einen
Solarpark zu investieren wird in naher
Zukunft ein etabliertes Verfahren sein
gleiches gilt für den Kauf von Strom aus
verschiedenen
Energiequellen im Bereich der
Solarenergie haben die ersten
Energieversorger ihre Anlagen bereits
tokisiert
auch bei den Windkraftanlagen gibt es
Plattformen die Betreiber der Anlagen
mit Unternehmen und Privatpersonen
zusammenbringen durch die tokenisierung
werden die Eigentümer der Token zu
mititeigentümern einer
Windkraftanlage durch den Verkauf des
Stroms erwirtschaften sie eine anteilige
Rendite aber auch die Betreiber der
Anlagen profitieren für sie ist die
tokenisierung eine weitere Möglichkeit
um das Kapital der Anlage direkt
einzusammeln sie erhalten dadurch
Reichweite und Zugang zu hoher
Liquidität doch bislang wird Energie
noch überwiegend zentral verwaltet bis
die neue Technologie sich durchsetzt ist
es noch ein weiter
[Musik]
Weg der nächste große Schritt ist nun
die Anbindung von
Nachbarschaften genauso wie bei größeren
Projekten für erneuerbare Energien
werden nun ganze Gemeinden im Austausch
für die Erlaubnis zur Errichtung eines
Solar oder Windparks an der Nutzung der
erzeugten Energie beteiligt und dies
wird Gemeinschaften schaffen die in der
Lage sein werden Energie untereinander
auszutauschen und zu
handeln wir sind also bereits auf dem
richtigen
Weg ich denke dass Deutschland
wahrscheinlich der größte Markt für
solardachanlagen in Europa ist
Deutschland hat in dieser Hinsicht die
meisten Installationen aber man sieht
diesen Trend auch in Frankreich dort
gibt es eine sehr strenge Regulierung
wie auch im Vereinigten Königreich und
Italien dies ist ein gesamteuropäischer
Trend die Rufe nach Nachhaltigkeit
Menschenrechten oder Tierschutz werden
seit Jahren hörbar lauter die
Gesellschaft fordert zunehmend Produkte
deren Entstehung transparent nachweisbar
ist die tokenisierung der Lieferkette
steht für eine glaubwürdig Zukunft der
produkttransparenz spannend wird die
Technologie im Hinblick auf das neu
verabschiedete Lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichtenesetz es soll belegen
dass menschenrechtliche und
umweltbezogene sorgfalltspflichten nicht
verletzt
wurden Unternehmen werden verpflichtet
jeden Schritt der Lieferkette für
Behörden und Verbraucher zu
dokumentieren Nachhaltigkeit soll
dadurch nachvollziehbar prüfbar und
sichtbar werden die tokenisierung Macht
die Nachverfolgung des Produktes entlang
der gesamten Wertschöpfungskette möglich
über ein handelsübliches Smartphone
werden alle relevanten Informationen zu
einem Produkt gesammelt und in einem
Token gespeichert dies geschieht von
allen Standorten der Welt aus ohne
technisches Vorwissen der Mitarbeitenden
per App kann jede Art von Information
gespeichert werden jeder
Produktionsschritt und jeder Rohstoff
innerhalb der Lieferkette sind so
jederzeit zuverlässig
abrufbar
so werden globale Lieferketten lückenlos
nachvollziehbar während bei dieser
Berichterstattung eine auf der
blockchain Technologie basierende
Lieferkette für eine lückenlose
Dokumentation sorgen kann kann
künstliche Intelligenz dabei helfen eine
entsprechende Risikoanalyse
durchzuführen so kann die KI
beispielsweise Verträge mit Lieferanten
auf Menschenrechte und Umweltstandards
analysieren das ermöglicht dem
Unternehmen gegebenenfalls eine schnelle
Anpassung der vertraglichen Regelungen
mit
Zulieferer in der Landwirtschaft
ermöglicht die tokenisierung es den
Landwirten ihre Produkte in Token
umzuwandeln dadurch können
internationale Investoren in regionale
Agrarrohstoffe investieren im
Gesundheitssektor hilft die
tokinisierung medizinischen
Institutionen bei der Nutzung sensibler
Daten von Patienten und
Gesundheitsorganisation die
Logistikbranche arbeitet derzeit
ebenfalls an einem Konzept der toisier
hier soll der Frachtbrief in die
blockchain überführt werden und so ein
Problem der Verwaltung
lösen wenn die tokenisierung Teil des
zugrunde liegenden Prozesses für
Finanztransaktionen wird können wir
davon ausgehen dass die Gesamtgröße des
Marktes größer sein wird als das gesamte
heutige Marktvolumen für Finanzanlagen
das wird natürlich nicht über Nacht
passieren dies wird in mehreren
Schritten Geschehen abhängig von
Regulierung Innovation und
wir brauchen demokratische
Diskussionsprozesse wir brauchen ein
Management es könnte durchaus noch 5 bis
20 Jahre dauern es wird aber Schritt für
Schritt ein Wachstum des Marktes zu
sehen sein trotz der vielen Vorteile und
ihrer zunehmenden Verbreitung hat die
blockchain basierte tokenisierung von
Vermögenswerten auch ihre Grenzen ein
Nachteil den es heute generell bei Token
noch gibt ist die Skalierbarkeit der
zugrunde liegenden blockchains wenn man
heute das gesamte Wertpapiergeschäft was
es weltweit gibt auf eine blockchain
bringen wollte um alle Wertpapiere zu
tokisieren dann würden die blockchains
das Transaktionsvolumen was dort
abgewickelt wird nicht abbilden können
das bedeutet das System wäre einfach
überlastet und überfordert und das ist
wahrscheinlich einer der Hauptnachteile
von Tokens also die sind gar nicht in
dem technischen Token Standard enthalten
sondern eher in den zugrunde liegenden
Plattformen nämlich den blockchains auf
denen diese Tokens existieren
es besteht ein Risiko dass Hacker auf
die digitalen Vermögenswerte zugreifen
und diese stehlen die blockchain
Technologie selbst gilt als sehr sicher
trotzdem gab es Fälle von erfolgreichen
Hackerangriffen auf kryptobörsen und
andere blockchainbasierte Systeme die
Angreifer verschafften sich den Zugang
in der Regel nicht über die blockchain
selbst sondern über die Punkte an denen
die blockchain angeschlossen ist es
besteht daher die Notwendigkeit ein
umfassendes und zuverlässiges System zum
Schutz vor Cyberkriminalität zu
entwickeln wenn man sich die globalen
Regulierungen als Wasserfall vorstellt
dann würde ich sagen dass Europa an der
Spitze dieses Wasserfalls
steht und ich denke dass vieles von dem
was wir mit Mika in Europa erreicht
haben jetzt in die regulatorischen
Überlegungen anderer Staaten und
Rechtsordnungen
einfließt Banken haben seit jeher die
Rolle des Verwalters von
Vermögenswerten sie versuchen ihren
Aktionsradius zu erweitern und den
Kunden ein möglichst breites Spektrum an
Dienstleistungen anzubieten daher haben
sie bereits begonnen die tokisierung von
Vermögenswerten zu untersuchen es
könnten Banken sein die in Zukunft die
Emissionen und den Handel von
tokenisierten Vermögenswerten verwalten
fintech hat sich in den letzten Jahren
zu einer der am schnellsten wachsenden
Branchen
entwickelt
also ein Bereich in dem Moment sehr sehr
viel Innovation bei Token stattfindet
ist die sogenannte
Zahlungsabwicklung da kann man auch die
wertpapiertken als Beispiel nehmen eine
Anleihe beispielsweise zahlt einen
regelmäßigen Coupon vielleicht einmal
pro Jahr an bestimmten Zins an
diejenigen die diese Anleihe halten man
kann den Token mit so viel Informationen
ausstatten dass er die Höhe des
zinskuppons kennt und beim Emittenten
den Zinsbetrag automatisch einzieht und
dann an die Investoren automatisch
verteilt in der traditionellen Welt in
der Bankenwelt gibt es dafür die
sogenannte Zahlstelle also wenn ein
Unternehmen eine Anleihe emittiert dann
gibt es eine Bank die wird als
Zahlstelle bestimmt und die sorgt dann
dafür dass der Emittent rechtzeitig
seinen Zins zahlt und schüttet diesen an
die Investoren aus und das kann man eben
durch Programmcode auch durch eben
sogenannte Smart contracts
automatisieren und diese Informationen
dem Token
mitgeben ökologischen Auswirkungen von
blockchain zu sprechen halte ich für
sehr wichtig aber wir als Branche müssen
uns fragen was richtig und was falsch
läuft viele Leute die das ganze von
außen betrachten denken dass hierfür der
gleiche Energiemix verbraucht wird den
wir täglich brauchen und so sehr das
auch der Fall war es hat sich radikal
geändert nun werden eine Menge
regenerativer Energien zur Erzeugung der
Notes einer blockchain genutzt wie
Wasserkraft Windenergie aber auch
Solarenergie und das ist Energie die aus
der Sicht des Verbrauchers bisher wenig
genutzt wurde sie konkurriert also nicht
mit der Energie die sie und ich in
unserem täglichen Leben verwenden mehr
als 60% der Energie die das
bitcoinnetzwerk verbraucht ist bereits
regenerativ und an den anderen 40%
müssen wir noch
arbeiten speziell die Finanzierung über
Token hat die Chance die Weltwirtschaft
in Zukunft drastisch zu verändern
Unternehmen werden reale Vermögenswerte
online abbilden und dezentral
finanzieren können bestehende
Finanzdienstleistungen werden durch
dezentrale Lösungen
ersetzt ich denke in Zukunft werden wir
wahrscheinlich im Bereich
kryptozahlungen eine Vielfalt von
verschiedenen digitalen Währungen sehen
es wird stable Coins Commercial Bank
money Token und auch verschiedene Arten
von cbdcs geben das Angebot wird
vielfältig sein oder wie man in
Deutschland sagt ein bunter Mix und ich
glaube nicht dass der eine unbedingt den
anderen verdrängen wird
auf der anderen Seite glaube ich dass
auch ein großes Interesse an
kryptowährungen besteht etwa 23% der
Europäer besitzen kryptowährungen
zumindest der Durchschnitt liegt bei 17%
wir liegen also noch unter dem globalen
Durchschnitt aber es wächst wenn also
die Menschen kein Vertrauen in das
bisherige System haben suchen Sie nach
alternativen und ich glaube das ist aus
politischer Sicht eine Herausforderung
für Regierungen wie schaffen wir
Vertrauen in unsere sy im Zeitalter der
digitalen Transformation darauf gibt es
keine einfache Antwort und ich glaube
gleichzeitig ist es vielleicht ein
bisschen naiv zu glauben dass
kryptowährungen alle Probleme der Welt
lösen können ich möchte sagen hier
brauchen wir eine Art gemäßigten oder
maßgeschneiderten
Optimismus es fehlt derzeit noch an
einer Standardisierung der Netzwerke
zudem müssen rechtliche Standards
entwickelt werden um Unternehmen und
gleichermaßen Klarheit und damit
Sicherheit zu verschaffen die
Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft
können wir bereits heute erkennen die
Technologie ist bereits im Hier und
Jetzt
[Musik]
angekommen